[Music]
welcome to another session of fiction so
we started out in with Paulo and now
we've got Chesterton we're looking into
people that were big influences on some
of the other thinkers that we looked at
before
again we're doing an innovation this
time actually put the some of the themes
that I thought would be interesting to
talk about on though the board since
we've had that this entire time you've
never used it
I thought maybe since I actually had my
marker along it would be a good idea as
usual I've got a you know some some
quotes for you and timeline and
Chesterton is somebody who I actually
encountered kind of late
I didn't start reading him until I was
in graduate school but I'd heard of him
because everybody mentions him it says
oh he's such a great essayist
and loves paradox and so it's such an
interesting guy in certain ways and it
was people that I liked who were talking
about him you know like for a borghese's
or CS Lewis or jr. Tolkien referring to
so I thought I'd better read him and I I
can't we were talking about use books I
bought a used copy of the man who was
Thursday and read that and I thought
well this is really interesting so then
I started buying up other things
including I remember I bought this in
Carbondale as well there's this
everlasting man at the same used
bookstore and then I went on after I
finished graduate school I went on a
Chesterton jag where you know that's
like where you read everything you can
buy the person yeah then I got kind of
you know I read enough to get tired of
him so I let it alone for a while but
I'd go back to it every so often and I
really do enjoy him he has been a
massive influence on lots of people who
we've we've looked at as I mentioned CS
Lewis talks about him Tolkien is
actually influenced to some degree by
his you know social theory that he
wasn't the only person
he's one of the main people with dish
was at the word wrong just distributism
I always want to say distributive ISM
but you know he's probably still in
casting a big shadow and a big shadow
because he was also a big fat guy too
all the way down to the president it was
a big fat guy who was fine joking about
his weight do you know that joke about
the who in World War one this woman
asked him why aren't you out at the
front and he said man if we go around to
the side you'll see that I have was a
tall guy they say somewhere between 62
and 64 probably wrong you know 280 300
pounds so did you know Louis and talking
or I've forgotten were than they were
born well they're they're somewhat later
they're a different generation okay so
he didn't know that no I don't think so
but and then there's other writers too
before him that that you know he would
have read and been influenced as well
but like like John Henry Newman for
example he was the Chester Turner was a
contemporary with like George Bernard
Shaw who he was very good friends with
and would fight with all the time
there's actually a movie that never got
released with the two of them in it he
would debate people he's like a
contemporary Bertrand Russell as well he
would debate him sometimes so yeah and
then he'd I was kind of young I mean not
surprisingly congestive heart failure
whenever they're overweight that sort of
thinking can quite easily happen to you
so he's born in 1874 and he's you know
he's the kind of guy who he travels a
lot in his life but he's really a
Londoner and he stays in that
area for the most part he goes to
schools and then he goes to this Slade
school of art starts doing some writing
our criticism wants to be an artist
doesn't graduate from there he actually
leaves there it starts working for this
publisher Redway and then quickly shifts
from them to 1t Fischer Unwin that was
kind of an important press at the time
and then he starts freelancing and this
guy was really pretentious when it comes
to his output if you think about the
amount of writing that he did he starts
writing art and literary criticism and
then eventually he starts branching out
and you notice like at certain times
they give him weekly columns well that
means you have to write an essay a week
and essays are I mean tough to write as
it is but to do it week after week after
week after week consistently on that
that's quite tough he also meets this
this woman Francis blog they don't marry
for quite a while five years in part
because in order to get married you
actually had to have some money and you
know it sound like today where though
they'll give you a license you know just
walk into the courthouse you needed in
some prospects and he wasn't he wasn't
financially solvent enough for for quite
a while but apparently was one of those
love it foresight sort of things for him
and she was quite brilliant herself she
ended up in many respects taking a kind
of traditional support role she she
handled for example his bookings so
there's a famous story of him
telegraphing to her and saying I forget
exactly where I met this station where
am I supposed to be you know so it's
sort of like we would you know look at
our phone to figure out where we were
supposed to be that's what he's doing
with her but he had somewhat of an
intellectual and and you know certainly
affectionate equal in her he writes for
there's this this thing the speaker and
you know it's interesting I'll say this
to a lot of people
including myself because Chesterton was
was a Catholic by the time that he dies
and then during some of his his writing
period I just assumed he was a Catholic
his whole life the way that he he writes
about things but he wasn't he was a
Anglican you know from a family that was
kind of you know Leslie fare about what
that meant but anglicanism was kind of A
mish-mosh anyway that way it's kind of
like a big big umbrella term and he was
always very interested in traditional
religion he eventually becomes what
you'd call an Anglo Catholic which is
the Anglicans who are more influenced by
the Catholics which is kind of in you
know here in America not that big of a
deal but it Britain you know they're
really looked down upon I mean in the
early days in America Catholics were
really quite despised and then they
could be even in some areas but you know
by the time that that he's there there's
still kind of an appropriate to being
being a Catholic and in England and so I
assumed he was Catholic the whole time
but he wasn't he he slowly moves his way
into it in a lot of ways and he's he's
influenced by documents by Catholics
before he's a Catholic so this whole
distributive ISM the distributism thing
it's coming out of you know like the
Pope writing rerum Novarum in the 1800's
Chesterton's not actually converting
into long after he's already sort of
thought this this what he did yeah he
was actually a late lay preacher in st.
Paul's Church so he's talking and you
know there is an Anglican and you notice
he's most of the people that we look at
I don't put all their books in there
I've got most of his books in here just
so you can get an idea of the literary
output and the range of Chesterton some
of it is you know stories like like
these ways of alma cross or the flying
in or man who was Thursday some of them
are selections of short stories there's
of course the father Browns
raise you know which all detectives with
this father brown guy who's based on a
real life person and then there's poetry
you wrote a ton of poetry wrote a lot of
essays he wrote some books like like
these too you know specifically on a
particular topic you know discussions of
the Gospels his views on orthodoxy
itself
he also wrote a lot of literary
criticism so you noticed like for
example in 1903 he they must have been a
really good year for him he turns out a
book on Robert Browning Charles Dickens
Tennyson Thackeray Leo Tolstoy all admit
I haven't read these these literary
biographies I'm not I'm not that
interested in that sort of stuff
compared to both the certain books that
I have here and the essays but he's you
know he's good at that and he keeps on
doing those those were probably I would
imagine good moneymakers too you know so
as he's going on he's writing he starts
writing weekly columns he meets this guy
father John O'Connor who will be the
model for for father brown we'll talk
about why that matters in a bit and then
eventually in the 1910s
they get this he and his brothers Cecil
who's younger than him and Hilaire
Belloc get this distributive ISM
distributism project off and running and
they start publishing a series of papers
each one of which like sort of folds up
and starts a new one and and the whole
idea is to have a new social theory
that's not conservative it's not liberal
it's not a communist it's not capitalist
it's something it's a different
alternative that would be you know full
sort of fuller exemplification of social
justice
we'll talk about that in a bit when the
war comes of course he's he's a bit
older but his brother Cecil enlists in
the Army in the infantry and converts to
Catholicism his brother also gets
married at the time to a woman who
appears I forget I think your name was
Ida she kind of trades on the Chester to
name a good bit because Chesterton's
kind of famous by this time
Cecil ends up dying in France and
shortly after that Chesterton is is
doing his first lecture tours he goes to
Palestine which was under British
control at that time and to Italy then
he goes to America he's doing that from
21 to 22 oh that should be Helen Keller
and that Hegel Keller B it's Helen
Keller Ernest Hemingway and at the end
of that year he converts to Catholicism
and he's received into the church by
that priest father O'Connor was he
married
yeah he got married in where is this 19
1901 no sorry his wife converts four
years later see that's what I was
learning about you know tol Keenan Lewis
because they yeah - but I didn't have
any idea with her later in cameo - no
but was there a literary group that were
sort of oh yes yes so I saw a token was
Catholic yeah I didn't convert like no
no but Louis I mean Louis did convert
right and Tolkien and Louis are at there
at the university right Chesterton's not
a university guy he's a journalist guy
he always builds himself as a journalist
so they're you know it you could say in
a literary way they're all on the same
big soup right but they're not they're
not at the same place
so and that probably today that wouldn't
make that big of a difference with it
because we have you know we're so
connected but back then that would that
would actually be quite important about
being in that Oxford he you know
environment so and then you know like I
said as his wife converts about four
years later he becomes president of the
distributist League he visits Poland he
visits Rome there he is quite
interesting interviews Mussolini and he
also has an audience with the Pope so
you know he's got a lot of pull by that
and then he goes on his second American
lecture tour in nineteen thirty so right
of the you know start of the depression
and shortly after that he's invited by
the BBC to give a first set of radio
talks and this is you know when radios
really taking off and at first he's kind
of reticent to do it but then he like
everything else he throws himself into
it and he starts giving about forty
talks a year and he does that till he
dies now forty you know forty talks a
year doesn't sound like that much but I
mean think about like putting up for a
podcast hear really good podcasts that
would be a lot of work yeah even if
you've got other people doing all the
editing and stuff right you got to have
cogent thought and with that those radio
talks it's not like you you just you
could just get out and wing it and
they'll edit the bad stuff up you're on
the radio so rambling at the same time
you know well that's the other thing
though you got to get a different talk
each week right you can't just
regurgitate the same material I mean he
had so much material by that time
I mean he traveled everywhere so I mean
he could say oh this week I'm gonna talk
but when I met whistling truly I mean
yeah well and to write the amount of
stuff that he he broke just because he
this entire time while he's doing doing
all this he's still keeping up the you
know one weekly column so he's writing
essays in and you know I I've had a hard
time keeping up just sometimes with my
blog and I keep the the pressure pretty
low on though the quality of the
literary output for that he must had
some pretty high expectations for
himself and notice he's still like
churning out books this entire time to a
lot of years you know two or more books
and eventually you know he dies of
congestive heart failure but he writes
as a lot of biography at just the right
time doesn't he
it's his last year of his life I mean
it's kind of kind of an interesting
point to end that that timeline on if
you were gonna write your autobiography
wouldn't it make the most sense to do it
shortly before you are dying okay those
are those are good points so I you know
we we usually talk about world building
and and we can certainly do that with
Chesterton
I mean his his world is generally this
world only viewed through the eyes of
the characters and revealed quite often
has richer than at first looks right so
the man who was Thursday you know there
is a bit of fantasy stuff in there I'd
say but for the most part what's
happening is people are explaining
what's going on and this ties in with
some of these themes what we first see
in the world you know usually viewed
through the eyes of the characters and
through dialogue never turns out to be
exactly what really is the case that's
always revealed through further action
and further dialogue and it's a world
that we're used to of you know people
who are on the make and people who are
trying to earn a living and people who
are you know exercising power and people
who are in desperate circumstances he
doesn't you know he doesn't set his
stuff and some mythical past or anything
like that but I think it's because he
thought this world was already magical
enough or there was enough of a per me
permeation of the world the sort of
materialistic humdrum daily world by
whatever you want to call it the
supernatural the miraculous the the
dazzling I think that's that's part of
what was going on I mean you've read
Chesterton do you think there's anything
more to say about his world building or
finally read the man who was Thursday
because they could what everything else
that's only one I could find
yeah I think it could bear a second
reading I do there's yeah there's so
much in there you know I mean it's
almost seems like a dream state like you
said nothing is what it is yeah the
character of Sunday really could use
some study because is he really the
master and none of these are did the
whole the concept of Anarchy as being
you know a thing of the rich as opposed
to the poor the poor they just uh prized
but they entered if the true anarchists
who wanted to reach out there I think
are there they're rich in parlor and in
in this Thursday you know going through
the big fat man head and then just just
the characterization of him with his
head and he just keeps going like he's
almost a supernatural sort of thing and
Sunday the character of that in he's
very elusive all the way through you
just never really know
this is I mean you can figure out
immediately that all these guys are I
mean they're all did their things but
you know we're not you caught on right
away that they are all cops well I was I
was in that was actually my one of my
favorite parts of the book is when they
all realize that they're all cops all
undercover checking up on each other
they've totally been wasting their time
well yeah but I I yeah after the second
one it just after Tuesday you know the
pool but I can't think of the name and
then I started to think okay there's the
theme going on here yeah and then the
last one with the secretary they're
really doing they're trying to stop the
bomb analysis and this is yeah he is too
so um yeah that I tie read a lot of
mysteries so that I'm pretty good at
that so anyway but it it just it was
very like was this a dream like in the
end he's what he's Simas walking with
that the fellow who started um Gregory
Gregory the actual anarchist and was i I
just thought I really need to read this
think yeah because it was yeah it was a
lot of paradise called the nightmare so
yeah is it a fantasy work I mean the
nightmares became a dream right so what
it was like sign didn't even know he had
experiences for it was a dream it seemed
like he was talking with Gregory to say
you know what this really yeah you know
and it was like a paradox I mean there's
a lot of paradox I will say like so that
notion of things being a drinks on the
ball across you have these two
characters both of whom are Scotsman and
both of whom are very grounded in a
certain way but also kind of crazy but
they're less crazy than the whole world
around them one is an atheist and he's
the kind of atheist it takes atheism
seriously he owns a shop and he like
publishes atheist tracks and then you
know the other guy who's from Scotland
and we normally think of the Scots as
being Protestants right but there there
was this remnant of Kapil's the
Highlander
yeah the Jacobites and so he's one of
them
and he comes down to London and he sees
the guys he's there it's to see that the
Cathedral and then he sees this guy shop
and he sees attract about Mary just
being essentially a remix of a Sumerian
or Babylonian goddess and he breaks the
guys window and challenges them to fight
so then they get brought before the
magistrate and the magistrate just wants
to smooth all this out and the Scots the
The Scotsman who's the Highlander he's
like I'm gonna fight this man no matter
where and and the judge is like death
come on you're you're really being a
pain you know being a stickler about
this and then eventually though the
atheist says I won't fight him don't
worry about it your honor I don't know
so they go out and then the Scotsman
turns to him and he says or aliyev
everything this Gasman turns to the
other Scotsman that says okay where and
when do you want to fight and that's the
whole rest of the story is them
attempting they managed us to steal two
swords and they're gonna duel to the
death because it really matters and
everything around them at one point they
actually say I think we're entering into
something boats were yeah so there's the
balm cross they're having one of their
many discussions and the first one says
Mr Turnbull I have nothing to add to
what I've said before it strongly borne
in upon me that you and I the sole
occupants of this runaway cab is early
on are at the two-month at this moment
the two most important people in London
possibly in Europe I've been looking at
all the streets as we went past I've
been looking at all the shops I've been
looking at the churches and first I felt
a little dazed or the vastness of it all
I could not understand what it meant but
now I know exactly what it means it
means us this whole civilization is only
a dream you and I are the realities and
then mr. talk turned while the atheist
says religious symbolism does not as
you're probably aware appeal ordinarily
to thinkers of the school to which I
belong but and symbolism as you use it
in this instance I must
I think concede a certain truth
we must fight this thing out somewhere
because as you truly say we have found
each other's reality we must kill each
other or convert each other I used to
think all Christians were hypocrites and
i felt quite mildly towards them really
but now I know you're sincere and my
soul is mad against you
in the same way use you used I supposed
to think all atheists thought atheism
would leave them free for immorality and
yet in your heart you tolerated them
entirely now that you know I am an
honest man and you were mad against me
as I am against you
that's it can't be angry with bad men
but a good man in the wrong why one
thirst for his blood yes you offered
open for me at Vista of thought and so
the idea is that the people who are
really committed to something and
certainly they're more real and the rest
of it's all just kind of BS that people
you know juggle around and shift around
but it doesn't really matter you know
it's all kind of fake and so it's not
quite a dream but but it's kind of
similar to that that dream state is that
alternate reality kind of thing is that
kinda wouldn't just seemed like to that
oh yeah there's this reality that yes
yeah and then there's this alternate
kind of reality where everybody's in a
disguise nobody is who they are yeah
and that reality kind of you know kind
of superimpose I don't know it was just
like I said I think it could bear a
second reading just because there was a
lot of you know like I think there's
influence when you said that or at
school I think you know that was
influencing career that's a good that's
a good and a couple of other things that
I was when I was reading up after I read
this I thought yeah I could see some of
this stuff was coming through you know
that's a good some of his it's a pretty
gnarly book you know so it's nothing far
out art school I was like you know they
made a reference to a telephone I
thought were they even have telephones
in 1508 that I know they were very
rudimentary in cars you know there
would've been
Metiria cars but even the people who
were like when they were when they're on
the run from the so called you know
secretary even though they move anyway
when their other running in the cars at
end and then the professor knew all
these guys these guys are not going to
help him but the guys are all I ever
kissed you it was just like this is a
whole massive world of deception and
then Simon is just trying to you know
wheel through all of this and it was you
know I thought it was you know he's
hiring is kind of funny with that too
cuz so he's you could say he's he's like
a detective right he's an undercover guy
but he's all honored he's very spiritual
me there's a whole lot of spirituality
and the assignment he doesn't know who
was actually giving him the assignment
and it's you know he's like I don't I'm
not actually qualified for this by you
were qualified enough you know what am I
supposed to do well you'll figure it out
you know that was there was the biggie
dark headed man that might have been
Sunday later on you notice he said I'm
the man in the dark shadows yeah yeah I
mean the whole thing with the elephant
running around the balloon I mean it was
just so yeah and in a way I mean is this
absurdist literature there was a lot of
absurd very absurd in there that's quite
a service actual absurdness literature
but it definitely was almost like a
children's book and some yeah there was
an element of the absurd in quite a few
of us like see what sort of like Lewis
Carroll right no well that was more
satirical absurdity where this is just I
don't know
Chesterton's certainly satirizing a lot
of people he a lot of business people
are kind of standards for ideas that are
prevalent at the time again to talk
about the ball in the cross so these
guys they want to fight and they're
prevented over and over again from
fighting like though the police won't
let them fight they want
Lock them up and one of the first things
that they do folks these two
philosophers that they meet and the
chapters are actually called something
like the first philosopher and the
second philosopher was here the
peacemaker and the other philosopher so
they mean it like a Tolstoy and kind of
guy who's like oh we have to be nice to
each other
let's not fight and the the two before
that the two men are getting to know
each other and they're getting closer
and closer like not fighting
and then the Tolstoy young guy comes in
and he's like we have to be gentle we
have to be nice what to make and they're
like well ready to fight now
you know this guy's cool you know and
then they they they the cops are after
them they go to another place there's
another guy who's like oh I'll let you
fight all you want because I'm he
doesn't use the word Nietzschean but I
think it's a neat you reference he's
like you know everything is about force
and blood and I just love I'll do
anything to make it possible for you to
fight the guys talking and talking and
talking and so finally he who's the the
Catholic he grabs the other sword and he
puts in the guy's hand he said fine
fight me and the guys like oh no no I'm
not gonna fight I want to see you guys
fight and they're truth to see whose
truth it is yeah but well the point is
that the second philosophy is a great
windbag about how and everything is
brutality but he's not willing to
actually step up and fight he just wants
to watch other people do it you know so
I said there's a lot of satirizing of
other people in this I think that's
that's quite true well let's talk about
the paradox thing so I actually have a
few things about paradoxes that I
thought could be interesting
Chesterton is called the Prince of
paradoxes sometimes it can get a little
tiresome I think how everything can be
twisted and turned but he is quite good
at doing it so here's something he says
in orthodoxy mere light sophistry is the
thing I happen to despise most of all
things and it's perhaps a wholesome fact
this is the thing
generally accused I know something's I
know nothing so contemptible as a mere
paradox a mere ingenious defense of the
indefensible if it were true that George
that mr. George Bernard Shaw lived upon
paradox and he ought to be a mere common
millionaire for a man of his mental
activity could invent a sophistry every
six minutes it's as easy as lying
because it is lying the truth is that
mr. Shaw is cruelly hampered by the fact
that he cannot tell any lie unless he
thinks it's the truth
I find myself under the same intolerable
bondage so what he's saying there's
there's two kinds of paradoxes there's
like the glib easy to come up with
paradox where you just like twist
something at its head like people do
this with with what's called the
rhetorical device of key azzam the
crossing where somebody will say you
know you shouldn't cheat your spouse and
then he might say yes but should you a
spouse cheating and sounds very profound
right you're just twisting it around
there's actually a really funny scene in
a super like a spoofing superhero movie
where there's this guru who everything
that they say he just twists it around
like that and then after a while they
can try and learn like you're full of it
you know you don't actually know
anything so that that's a superficial
kind of paradox so what is a deeper
paradox it's a paradox about things that
actually looks at how strange they
really are when we when we look at them
more closely and so I here's one example
I'll just skip over the reforming thing
we can come back to that in a bit the
one from the everlasting man he's
talking about people and and what they
have to say about the contrast between
Jesus or the church and Jesus of the
Gospels he says we've all heard people
say a hundred times over for they never
seem to tire saying it the Jesus of the
New Testament is indeed a most merciful
and humane lover of humanity but the
church has bidden this human character
in repellent dogmas and stiffened it
with ecclesiastical terrors till it's
taken out a in human character and he
says this is almost the reverse of the
truth
because if you actually read the Gospels
this guy's scary as hell he is saying
stuff you know in these these parables
himself and he's very cut and dry
there's the goats there's the Sheep you
know there's so many things that you're
not supposed to do that's in the Gospels
that's the Jesus then that actually gets
gets recorded so he says it's the image
the truth is the image of Christ in the
churches is almost entirely mild and
merciful it's the image of Christ in the
Gospels that is a good many things as
well the figure in the Gospels in utters
and words of almost heartbreaking beauty
his pity for our broken hearts but
they're very far from being the only
sort of words he entered via utters
they're almost the only kind of words at
the church and it's popular imagery ever
represents it as honoring and so so it
makes sense right that the poor are
broken the mass of the people are poor
and the mass of for the mass of mankind
the main thing is to carry the
conviction of the incredible compassion
of God but nobody with his eyes open can
doubt that it's chiefly this idea of
compassion that the popular machiner the
church does seek to carry the popular
imagery carries a great deal success the
sentiment of a gentle Jesus meek and
mild and you know if you look at the
Gospels this guy is like telling rich
people oh you're not going you're not
going to happen if you're not going to
heaven you're going to hell alright it's
easier for spreading the Gospel of Luke
right it's easier for a camel to pass
through the eye of a needle than a rich
man to enter into the kingdom of heaven
imagine if you're rich and you're had no
taste for piracy I mean you just don't
lead it right out there you know well
wherever think of the young rich man
right the young rich man who actually
like follows all the commandments and
does everything that he's supposed to do
and seems to be motivated by love and it
goes to this Jesus guy who you know at
this point in time has not been ratified
as the Son of God or anything and he
says hey I had the retinue teacher I've
done all the stuff I'm supposed to do
and he says oh yeah okay cool sell
everything you got give it to the poor
and follow
and then the young man goes away unhappy
and I think if you if you think about it
yeah of course he goes away out happy
because he just he's been doing
everything and he's being expected to
like do this other crazy stuff so that's
kind of a paradox right now why is it
this goes to the the sort of appearance
and reality thing why is it that people
have these these mixed-up ideas and
would say oh it's the church that's got
the mean Jesus we just got to go back to
the Gospels and find the the real nice
Jesus it would be because they don't
actually look at things closely they
don't read the Gospels because if they
did they would see that it's full of
statements like that oh you know you're
angry with your brother you're liable to
the judgment you know I say if you you
know even look at a woman with lust in
your heart you've already committed
adultery this guy is like raising the
bar way up here and it's clear from page
one being you know
well not page one but pretty close and
in Matthew Mark Luke and John that
that's that's the case how would
somebody not have that idea it would be
because they read it in a book somewhere
or a pamphlet somewhere or in our days
they watch The History Channel and saw a
special where somebody was saying yeah
the Gospels that's the nice Jesus and
the church that's been the really mean
Jesus over here right and they they took
in some ideas from somewhere and got it
mixed up and then we could say the same
thing about like the little thing about
the poor right and this stuff about the
anarchism do the poor really want
anarchy
we often get this this picture even
today like well yeah let the poor people
have their say and it's going to be
chaos
you know like think about voting rights
right do you want justice they don't
want anarchy yeah and they don't get
justice by by subversive B's but not a
nor anarchy is complete overthrow of you
know the government they don't want that
they just and what is that who can that
possibly benefit only somebody who
powerful and rich
so you know we we I think we have a lot
of these things where the appearance and
in reality are kind of mixed up and
Chesterton was pointing out that out in
his own time in ways that are sometimes
irrelevant and sometimes less relevant
you know this one actually is quite
quite funny the flying in they pass a
law that puts pubs in a weird catch-22
you're not allowed to have a sign to
advertise your pub but without a sign
you can't serve beer liquor so the idea
is to essentially impose what we call a
prohibition right in in England on the
entire country but to do it by this is
this legal machinery so these guys these
two guys form flying in and flying
doesn't mean flying there it just means
you know going from place to place and
there are these agents of subversion but
subverting things back to how they used
to be you know that people can actually
drink this is this this book by the way
cap Chesterton massively criticized for
promoting alcohol abuse your critics are
like you're you're actually you know
saying that people should drink as much
as they want so yeah I mean it's here in
Wisconsin as I'm sort of preaching to
the choir right we have a long tradition
of the British you have the pub you know
as the sort of institution we have the
tampers and the tavern many we don't or
the counter the corner bar right it's
many of them aren't like that anymore
but it used to be a place where you go
and there were some drunks but but a lot
of people would you know
your buds yeah and and parents would
bring kids in for a fish fry or things
like that and you could actually it was
a good place to actually observe people
not drinking too much to learn how to
handle your liquor in a way you know I
mean you could also see the drunks at
the end of the bar it's just sitting
there but yeah you know that's the sort
of thing that he's sort of protecting
and projecting in there so you know with
with with appearances and in realities
it's it's important to attend to what's
actually there and sometimes you know we
would pass over it too quickly or we
accept some reading from the media which
I think he saw is a big of a problem
that is people do now say with you know
the internet and proliferation of things
you know sort of timely thing there have
been a lot of firings at newspapers
lately right including the Journal
Sentinel here in Milwaukee and but if
you ever do you ever go on the Journal
Sentinel webpage it's just a mess
you know the ads everywhere you know
like a paper tape yeah and even the
paper papers have gotten really thin oh
yeah compared to no kidding yeah
Time magazine you pick it up it's not
recycled news yeah it's very good very
light and you know maybe what we're
getting through through all of that is
highly mediated and just sort of
regurgitating the same ideas which are
appearances they're not actually getting
us to the reality of things I think
about it you know new news stories and
how easy it is to skew them one one way
or the other you know yeah I mean the
news media as we've known it it sort of
curated
yes I mean they're appointed or they've
come into this source of power editing
or whatever you want to call it that as
a curator yeah but they have some
credentials to do that and sure they can
err on one side or the other but I mean
there's some controls there's less even
less because well there's less but I
mean then you go the opposite is sort of
the wisdom of the crowd yeah like okay
if a hundred thousand people say black
is white does that mean okay we've just
been wrong all these years and yeah our
color I you know what and so or does
somebody curates it now guys come on
what are you thinking just because
hundred thousand people buy into
something yeah that's the opposite so
you know I so we have to sort of flawed
things there right and then I don't
think the downsizing of print or other
mass media is because of the failure of
the architecture of it I think it's just
been overwhelmed economically that
people have loved it they call it the
eyeballs you're in a battle for eyeballs
yeah yeah you know whether in who's the
head of Netflix is who's your biggest
competitor you know video games you know
how does that occur but because I mean
yeah it's just like it's not another
Netflix it's just there's only so much
time you can come in so I can't Bowl
want a quick reward and fire off their
endorphins by whatever form of
entertainment they get yeah they and
there's no loss there's no restraint
there's no what's the cost that they
don't see a cost and maybe they don't
also see a reward but I mean they
meander and they float to something
that's quick and easy yeah and in the
mass media or Time magazine you know or
even an old Milwaukee Journal was all
about you know what are you going to
commit to read how many pages on a given
subject matter and I was like this
attention span thing is just like well
that's old but I'm done saying yeah I I
don't think it's like you suggested
maybe it's
because it was faulty yet its core in
terms of promoting a certain reality oh
I wasn't saying event I wasn't saying
that was though that was the reason for
the decline I'm saying that's a--that's
a function of the decline the fact that
they have less reporters that they don't
have fact check because I can't say from
exactly they don't keep investigating
reporting that these journalism is
massively decline in what it used if
anything about the we know we used to
have first the journal and the sentinel
all right
and then it became the Journal Sentinel
remember how everyone went crazy over
that but that was still pretty good and
you know they have fewer and fewer
people actually working at the journal
now they they recycle they still do some
investigative reporting but a lot of
what they do is just recycling ap stuff
you know much competition well this
online business you know there's yeah
and there are news sources that aren't
even matter right that's that's it we're
not in a position of political Anarchy
but we are in a time of information in
Turkey I think that's exactly right you
know and that means ultimately truth
anarchy in terms of what is their
reality what is the better reality of
the more truthful real reality as
opposed to what comes quickly so when it
comes to some of the really really big
picture stuff we may not be able to get
at the reality when it comes to like
what's happening what happening locally
with people that we actually know we're
not they're not cut off from it we might
actually be you know in some respect
because of like the proliferation of
social media provided we don't just like
buy into any one picture we might
actually be better off because we can we
can find out more and like you know get
the different takes and then then form
like a composite picture but when it
comes to like the global stuff we're
kind of screwed
it's very difficult to tell us into
babies
you just put on the like child tendon
eaters where they do where a global
perspective we're so out of it here yeah
well that's quite true too yeah our
amazing session narrows yeah but what's
going on you know it's just but people I
think I'm still vast majority people
can't deal with ambiguity and the reason
yeah as a method of finding the truth
and reality is by its nature questioning
and ambiguous and changing yeah and
faith as we've known any number of
faiths what does it bring to them first
and foremost seventeen I like 70 it
wasn't disrupt me out it doesn't
undercut me I can say in this faith and
somewhere out there I like the rules
give me the rules
give me the structure that's where
somebody like Chesterton who writes a
lot about this would say that for many
people what they call reason is really
just a kind of faith you see these
people who get out there and they're
like you know that's not logic that's
not reason that's not this and then you
look at the stuff that they're saying
and their commitments they're like just
as committed as some fundamentalist
religious believer is to like almost
like proof texting and things like that
and so this is actually a good thing
that well we can talk about this
appearance of reality one of the things
I wanted to bring up is this father
brown guy who I didn't you know I should
actually should have brought that it's
somewhere in series on the BBC news II
the books are pretty good because the
Father Brown Father Brown is is a he's
constantly running and people who want
to claim something as a miracle and he's
like don't talk about miracles let's
actually get to a rational explanation
of things he's the detective who's
solving things in part because he's not
willing to buy into any sort of
superstition about about stuff including
the superstitions of some scientific
people as well he wants to approach the
situation and figure out what's what's
going on so it makes him a good
detective now interestingly there's a
there's a thing that comes up in the one
of the Father Brown stories the same
thing happens
Green story where they're talking to a
priest and they somebody asked the
priest how do you get these insights of
the human nature he says well you know I
mean I studied some philosophy and
psychology when I was in seminary but
that's not really what it was actually
that that kind of set me behind it's
being in the confessional now why would
a actually sitting in the confessional
make you a good judge of human nature
because you hear people coming in and
spilling their guts about all the crazy
it does and lied about right and then
they tell you why they did the stupid
things they did and then you say okay
let's try not to do that you know
anymore and then you get a you know
penance and then they come back next
week and tell you about how they did the
same stupid thing but for a different
reason
and after a while you can kind of figure
out like what people are you know
different types of people and what
motivates people and when somebody
really is ready to change things when
when they're just giving you this line
at home father I really want to get my
life back on track
and and you know and a good confessor
can be like [ __ ] you don't want to
get your life on track you're gonna be
here next week you know now that would
be a way to in a way you think about
what the confessional does it cuts it
gets the person to go beyond the
appearances into the reality of who they
are and they you know I'm not saying
like they're revealing their entire
absolute true self but they're revealing
more of it than they reveal say when
they're with their friends at a party
right rester would say your penance
instead of saying some silly is to just
not be doing this thing you know Kevin
don't come back with me you know
probably do I didn't even hear a funny
story about a priest in my my family his
name was father and father John and we
had two great uncles in my you know my
grandfather's generation who were
priests and one of them I think I may
have mentioned this before one of them
should never have been a priest he was
kind of ladies man and his mom said
we're gonna put the kibosh on that
you're becoming a priest and like you
know I don't know what was going through
his head he was like okay you know I'll
do that if he became a Viator Ian and he
was as sour as hell you know he'd get
fired brimstone sermons
and like we had a family we have a
family reunion every year and one year
you know it was very hot it was like a
hundred degrees you know and we didn't
have air conditioning or anything but we
did have a pool so everybody's going
around with their swimsuits
he gave this sermon about how like you
know we're all we're all living in sin
looking at each other in swimsuits we're
all going to hell so he was that kind of
frustration there yeah well that's right
and now he was actually sort of a local
legend in the Viator Ian community
because I like met other bhaiyya
torian's and I I mean my uncle's of
Auditorium I'd say I'd say they'd say
who and I'd say father art and then
father LaBrie's oh he's like a legend
for his austerity his strictness you
know now father John he was a younger
brother he didn't have to become a
priest he wanted to become a priest and
he was sort of the you know he was not
the opposite but he was a compliment to
father father
art and he would do things like with my
mom's generation it was shortly after of
like Vatican 2 he would like take a walk
with them they out they had a farm out
in Indiana and then all the cousins
would would go to although although my
grandparents generation bought this farm
so they'd have a place to take the kids
out of the city in the summertime and
stuff like that so he would like to say
let's take a walk and then they'd walk
along and my screw-up cousins would you
know tell him about what was going out
of their life and how they got drunk
this time and we're you know screwing
around on the job with this and then you
know after a while you know he'd say to
them is there anything else going on in
your life they'd be like no I think
that's pretty much it and they say okay
I'm gonna give you absolution you know
here's your penance just you know he was
actually sort of liturgical II what he
was doing was not correct yeah but his
heart was in the right place he was
leading them through confession
confession was about figuring out what
it would have screw up you are so you
can like unscrew yourself up a bit right
you know
and then so father brown cannot kind of
fit them to that I would say one of the
other things I wanted to talk about is
the characters on this especially the
man who is Thursday they all have some
sort of commitment right and that's
that's what makes them the character
that they are I mentioned the guy who's
the Nietzschean in here or the two guys
that want to kill each other because
one's an atheist who really believes it
the other one is a Catholic who really
believes it other people stand in for
other things right so so some people
stand in for this doctrine or the Abba
doctrine and and some of them change but
most of them remain motivated by the
same basic set of desires or commitments
units they're prioritizations very often
we don't know what they are until they
they not everybody wears it on their
sleeve but you know the mystery stories
we find out as people interact and we
find out like what the real killer is
because the real killer wasn't motivated
by ideology they were motivated by
wanting to make money or things along
those lines that's part of why I got
like the club of queer trades and the
other one the man who knew too much he
had a great example of somebody he knows
too much his life kind of sucks because
he knows how bad people are because he's
constantly seeing how moral and
intellectual commitments of people made
which are not good ones damaged
themselves damaged the people around
them and this kind of fits in with where
was that
[Applause]
yeah so so in orthodoxy all right let's
get this the Christian admits the
universe is manifold the needed
miscellaneous just as the same man knows
that he's complex the same man knows
that he has a touch of the Beast a touch
of the devil a touch of the saint a
touch of the citizen the really saint
man knows he has a touch of the man man
but the materialist world is really
quite simple and solid just as the man
man is quite sure that he's sane
the materialist is sure histories have
been simply and solely a chain of
causation just as the interesting person
mentioned before is quite sure is simply
insolia and checking of man man
materialists and madmen never have
doubts religious people now there's
plenty of religious people that are like
that too like you were mentioning right
a lot of people want faith so they can
uncertainty and sometimes they actually
like jump from faith to faith to faith
like the church hop you know they're
like I thought you're in this church
over here now they were totally wrong
now I'm in this church they've got the
total answer but people do that with
other things too like they leave behind
a fundamentalist background and suddenly
they became a you know a secular scholar
and they're absolutely sure that the
Gospels are all mythical you know and
you're like well it seems kind of
excessive you know well it's that same
disposition of the world needs to be
simple and these can be quite complex
and in a sane person
Chesterton seems to think they're gonna
conflict with each other you're if
you're if you're crazy your life is a
lot simpler because you pick one thing
and you just follow that right and you
follow it all the way to the end if
you're saying you have a whole mishmash
of conflicting things that don't all fit
together well and I think for him his
religious conversion is something like
that it didn't make his life simpler it
made it more complicated and it made his
thinking more I won't say confused but
certainly you know more tangled and what
do you guys think about that
well you bet if you have converted from
something other than Anglican it's just
English Catholicism I mean I don't
really know that there's that much
difference I mean sure the the authority
the pulpit then there isn't a whole lot
of authority to fopen most catholic
lives inside but I mean they don't I
mean that's there but I mean he's that's
actually a good thing for us
consequential he's great forever
first of all Robeson is making money in
30 X or whatever is you know to convert
it was a small conversion to me well
that means if in 1906 you lined up okay
what are the top five tenets of one
versus the other that are really
different do you know if you didn't
wasn't yeah I mean okay because that's
something actually that's something I
wrote my dissertation of 1926 was when
axial Francaise was condemned by the
Vatican
accion Francaise was a very powerful
movement in France that was monarchist
you know sort of nominally Catholic but
claiming there was essentially a
proto-fascist movement and so the you
know there were some real stakes there
modernism it was in the middle of the
modernism controversy if you were
modernist you'd be you know you wouldn't
like right they would send me places
there was still a lot of anti-catholic
prejudice in England at the time Graham
Greene writes about this well I mean
this is no this is centuries after that
but there-there was it did mean
something and the Anglicans were kind of
a mess um oh he did you know so it did
mean something but to even uphold a sort
of Orthodox notion of Anglicanism
in a time when that meant you were
considered backwards was a big
commitment on his part but what did it
really change in terms of
what he was writing after he converted
oh I think there was a marked difference
in his worldview and things after he
just did that I think no I think it was
sort of like shifting bits and pieces of
it I think that that's why he converted
I don't think he converted then suddenly
changed his world after that I think he
changed his world he around
listen times he could convert yeah
earlier they just don't formalize it
yes brother we heard it and then I in
the war yeah and he may have just you
know that was 1918 or semi-circle
years later and yet the whole time
saying what am i brother see and what
happened and well that's that's a good
point you know in a conversion we we use
the term as if it's like a punctual
thing like it happened at this time and
then the person might went from from A
to B but really it's quite often a
conversion might take years and years
and years think about st. Augustine for
example you know in the confessions he
he buys into this part first and then
he's like yeah but by this but I don't
know about this stuff very different
what's up the confession is no I said
another very disturbed man you know my
guys got try yet guy had problems maybe
he's working out his own guilt off
usually he's a cool sink because he's a
saint that you can relate to guilt and
such as guilt he's um he was genuinely
the throughout his life you see this he
is motivated by the idea that there's
something more something better and he
does have somebody there's part of
philosophy I was really like Augusta but
I mean I looking at it from not
philosophical like when I was studying
more you know church history theology
and stuff heating in a diesel soon
you're talking
well that and that and other crappy
camera and it just really he was working
out a lot of his own mister yeah I mean
but he had mischief cuz he actually did
things and maybe he lived and screwed
around and had a kid
got involved in a cult yeah I mean so I
mean philosophers really like you know
this well I bet I don't know I just
he just doesn't resonate with me very
well my good student took a long time to
convert deathbed things almost no no no
it was that I know that was Bishop that
was counselor yeah yeah yeah that's the
answer
but why I'm gonna take a person a long
time to convert because the human person
is complex and again a sane person
doesn't change everything in their
viewpoint all at once it has to this
part has to change first and then this
part and then this part no this one
evolves on a realm of experience I mean
you just you know you have things and
then you just evolve you know based on
whatever well yeah I mean part of it
could have been through or an action is
to say okay if your sense of being an
anchor can is being eroded over a period
of years that it's just not real for you
the option is to say well maybe that's
part of organized religion this you know
before he goes to another I think it's a
mistake to frame it as like being an
Anglican was eroded he hear him no no
here's the other thing
he becomes a Catholic the way that that
most people that become conference from
one other denomination do not because
the there's an ism that they're
abandoning but because they think that
Christianity is most fully embodied yes
this is just like working just like when
somebody becomes leaves the Catholic
Church and becomes an orthodox church
member it's because they think the
Orthodox Church has got a better handle
on it it's not like he rejects
Anglicanism
and says in becoming a Catholic I have
juror all
Anglicanism you know or anything like
that
process Austin knowledge or not it's you
you decide I don't think that's you you
just start seeing things that are
appealing and start speaking to you and
yeah that's the kind of the way it goes
it's not a rejection of one it's the
embrace of another even if he was like a
pagan right like you've grown up without
any religion he wouldn't have to reject
paganism in order to become a Catholic
he would just say that's I've left that
behind
I think whatever they signed when
they're converting would dispute that
but I mean people well I don't
understand everything they sign but you
you've got your old dad thing in your
yeah you don't you don't sign anything I
mean I I was accepted back into the
Catholic you didn't sign you know I mean
what are you am speaking of we got to go
through training yeah yeah yeah you
think you know when you're confirmed you
you essentially recite the Creed which
which Anglicans do every mass anyway you
know so there's not a radical difference
there but you consider you because you
left the faith you came back to the head
to be converted them formally I've never
gotten confirmed oh so you were seeking
confirmation as a sacrament yeah I got I
left but I left I left I I like been she
sort of made a public declaration of I'm
done with this stuff while I was in
Catholic school and I it's okay but just
in terms of understanding the process so
if yeah you you or anybody then yeah
okay you didn't do it when you're 12
years old so now you're 24 years old or
something
yeah and you say well maybe I should
come back and do this so then the priest
is gonna say what what you've been doing
we've been up I mean you kind of miss
your boat here and now you're back but
we'll take you yeah I mean but it
depends on the piece whether he's gonna
sweat you about whether you really don't
know I have to make a mess or something
yeah of course
just go to
then you get your or you you know
there's all sorts of different ways you
can do it I did the same thing he just
got up and he says I'm not believing
this [ __ ] anymore noose nice let me
just walked right up you know it necks
yeah it's a you know it's fine I mean
it's it either either your it works for
you or it doesn't work for you well yeah
or you don't get I think part of the to
is you you the thing about like his
brother is probably important right you
see you see other people and how they
approach things and you say well is this
any different them being within this
church and not being within this church
and it makes you yeah okay I think
conversion for a lot of people is a
gradual process
you know you don't say damn I'm getting
converted you know you you know you
think about things and you ball them
over and you're like yeah that guy over
there like I thought Catholics were
really like backwards or something but
he's not you know and then then that
that changes things over time he's got
this here's another passage this is more
about politics but it's from a book
where he explains why he became a
Catholic and he says in the manner of
her forming things as distinct from
deforming them there's one plain and
simple principle a principle will
probably be called the paradox which is
what I put it here and the thing there
exists in such a case of certain
institution or law let's say for the
sake of simplicity a fence or gate
erected across such a road the more
modern type of reformer goes up to it
and says I don't see the use of this
let's clear it away to which the more
intelligent type of reformer will say if
you don't see the use of it I certainly
won't let you clear it away go away and
think and then when you come back and
tell me you do see you do see the use of
it I may allow you to destroy it
the paradox rests on the most common
sense elementary common sense the gaiter
fence did not grow there it was not set
up by some ambulance who built it in
their sleep it's highly improbable it
was put there by escaped lunatics who or
for some reason loose on the street
somebody had some reason for thinking it
would be a good thing for somebody to
or yeah so here yeah until we know what
the reason was we can't judge whether
the reason was reasonable because a lot
of reasons are unreasonable right it's
extremely probable we've overlooked
something aspect of the question if
something set up by human beings like us
seems to be entirely meaningless and
mysterious there's reformers who get
over this difficulty by assuming they're
all their fathers were fools but that'd
be so we can only say that folly appears
to be a hereditary disease the truth is
nobody has any business to destroy a
social institution so he's real until
he's really seen it as a historical
institution if he notice how it grows
and what purposes it was supposed to
serve then he can say that they were bad
purposes or that they become bad
purposes or their purposes which are no
longer served but if you simply stares
at the thing as a senseless Montross 'ti
that is somehow sprung up in his path
it's he and not the traditionalist who
is suffering from an illusion this often
gets quoted for love supporting a
certain kind of conservativism in
politics not a conservatism that would
be like any of the people that we call
conservatives today all of them would be
reformers of this sort because they're
all trying to change things very few of
them are actually trying to hold on to
things but he's actually bringing it up
in terms of religion and he's talking
about some of the things that say the
Catholic Church and held on to that the
England ganging up in church got rid of
and that's that's part of what he's
saying there's well maybe these things
work it wasn't good to get rid of them
we should have thought that through and
now notice he is saying hey there there
could be some stuff that you're like
yeah we understand why it's there
doesn't matter anymore that reason
doesn't apply
you know like Chesterton a few were
around today he might actually be quite
more quite a bit more liberal today than
he was back back then you know there was
the way we look at as being back then
but it's not a bad idea that we should
you know try to understand if we're
gonna say let's change this let's try to
understand what it is that we're
starting to change some things like
you know institutions that are there you
know foundered in racism like the you
know the blackface thing in virginia
right and so well it was a different
time as the 80s well in the 80s we know
it was wrong to do blackface up here at
least and if you know if we were going
to do it we expect to get in trouble but
[ __ ] said well what was the what was
the reason for doing blackface well it's
kind of an homage to Al Jolson that's a
terrible idea
right but at least if you bring it out
into the open you can figure out what
the hell it's about instead of just
saying down with this down with this
down with this I think that's actually
quite a good idea you see is saying we
need to actually make it clear what the
institution is and what its reasons are
and then we can critically examine the
reasons let's see whether they're good
he's assuming that the two different
parties can come to a common
understanding oh yeah exactly what
function is fulfilled yeah yeah and and
they have the time and the inclination
to do that as opposed to one being
totally outraged like black bears but
they just know it is so wrong I don't
have to articulate that yeah it's just
so wrong as racist and if you don't get
it's racist I'm not gonna sit here and
educate you about removing that fence or
whatever well I mean the thing is when
it comes to blackface it's not like this
is the very first time that the issue
has come up so there have been plenty of
discussions about you know is especially
online about you know how blackface of
rose and whether it's appropriate or not
so the fact that like these guys you
know never occurred to them that maybe
it's maybe somebody will dig in my past
and find this stuff and then I better
get ahead of this they you know you
could say well in the present they they
suddenly are placed on the spot well you
know it's not like this this discourse
hasn't been out there for a long time
you could say like if something new
happens your
and we're like get rid of this it would
be it would be a contemporary example
where like something like that would
happen
wanting to get rid of the electoral
college well people are wanting to get
rid of that for a long time though right
there's been a lot of discussion of is
it good is it bad
I remember you know hearing stuff about
that when I was a kid in the 80s
especially you know from Democrats
capture break and trout's mom David's
busy you know to use an example
yeah and it's a little bit of a complex
the electric power situation yeah but if
somebody two parties came to say this is
why they did it
yeah that's not necessarily the full
picture to say what are the consequences
it's now you did away with it yeah so
that's a little bit different sure
that's where you get into even more
complexity more intolerance for well
sure now coming to a clearer and
effective now answer he's not saying
it's gonna be an easy to do he is just
saying this is if you want to actually
like have some rational you know working
through these this is like having a
court for change and we don't have a
court for change very much in there what
we can do though let's say let's say
that some of us actually like did
operate this way and we and we who know
would probably take a lot of abuse oh it
was whole things down incredibly I mean
just like the doctors to feed it do no
harm
I mean yeah okay we're not gonna change
anything until we sit down calmly and
collectively with authority to say why
it was there to begin with I don't think
he's saying it has to be that no formal
right but he is giving you a useful
guide line and I think you know if you
say we shouldn't throw things out
willy-nilly yeah just because we have
the power to do so all right that's what
I think we do more things today of harm
by omission than by omission
yeah you mean like then we on that
to do things so we don't pay attention
to what we lose our giving up buy things
because we haven't felt an immediate
consequence for doing so and so we tend
to think of errors and crimes and yeah
and other bad acts as being an act like
an affirmative action to do something
and that's a something of commission we
can see well not always consciously but
you commit something to something but
how you let's think that we have more
consequential changes that are at work
over a longer period of time by
omissions and by coalition sometimes
sometimes there's a combination right
like when we somebody else does
something like you know think about how
little we actually participate in what
city government does like either the
Milwaukee
I don't go to common council meetings so
the county council does stuff and if I
were smart I'd actually go to them and
every once in a while like go down to
the microphone and say excuse me I think
this is a big idea right or you know
what's your reasoning for this right but
I don't do that and so I'm acting an
omission there right I'm not acting in
omission I'm not doing anything
it's an omission yeah but I'm letting
that was means consent yeah I'm letting
them do an action by Commission so I
think there's there's a lot of cases
like like that I know there's a lot of
cases where we can't really do anything
about it like if Amazon wants to think
you know the Amazons pulling out of New
York Milwaukee was out of the Amazon
running a long long time ago let's say
we want to put together a package if the
Amazon wants to come to Milwaukee they
will if they don't we don't have
anything to do with that right and if I
like they don't put my little thing on
Twitter stay out of here Amazon you know
that's not gonna be the difference right
but when it comes to smaller things I
could make a difference you know here's
an interesting example
so at Marquette they've gotten really
really strict about plagiarism in
academic dishonesty and it used to be in
the past we could kind of do it
informally like a student would
plagiarize they'd always do it and then
you'd catch them how far has passed
oh this changed this year
oh but dandy software programs that
hunted first oh yeah yeah and software
programs at flagon and what I'm saying
is formally means you don't go to the
plagiarism or the academic dishonesty
board and turn the student in instead
what you would do is you would like you
say to the student you get a zero on
this assignment cuz you plagiarized and
here's where you plagiarized from and
most of the time I don't even need to
use this software I can I can tell you
know this is coming from somewhere other
than the student that I just put it into
Google then the website comes up because
they're not very good at you know and
they the the thing came down from above
we are not allowed to do that anymore if
a student plagiarizes we must send it to
the zero tolerance yeah we have to send
it to the academic the academic honesty
or academic integrity board and now
that's extra paperwork for me and also I
don't like it because it goes on the
transcript whether they like you know
just they got referred yeah and so yeah
we circumstance that's right I don't
like it because of the inflexibility of
it and it doesn't allow me to work sort
of like work with the students to say
hey I'd like to see a non plagiarize
paper from you it just recently retired
editor publisher of the New York Times
writes your book oh there's a language
talk about somebody we should know would
be sensitive to all forms of plagiarism
and here she gets clock tonight okay
I'll fix that well I don't know this I
only know the headlines I know that I've
seen her interview yeah I'm in the past
as this highly credible in williston
yeah that was my Charlie Rose mm
plagiarism is a bigger problem I think
for people higher up you know I went to
Southern Illinois University the
president of
Illinois was glad for Sharn students dug
into his stuff the students on a daily
Egyptian they found that he plagiarized
massive sections I was master's thesis
and SP PhD dissertation and it came up
because he had overseen this policy and
that actually fired a professor for
plagiarizing by taking like a teaching
document and then copying some stuff
from it because there was some required
thing and so students were like well
this seems a little hypocritical you
know of course he got away with it they
looked into it the trustees they didn't
want to do anything about it so he even
wants a self-discovery resigned or is it
all just said you know what he said he
said you know I think I was reading that
stuff at the time but I don't think it's
really plagiarized of some of the
students were like this is line for line
at the same because I'm in here and then
he still said no no no it's not
plagiarism and because he's rich and
powerful position of power you feel
exactly like more things so yeah and so
that raises an issue too like is it is
it fair to punish the students in this
way you know they're they're they're you
know they're essentially the lower class
in the university ecosystem right there
as low as you can get and then
professors are slightly higher the
people who matter you know are the
people making the big decision this
would have like you know VP of this or
that after their day for teaching I mean
teaching is more than just parroting
knowledge it's showing how to deal with
consequences yeah that's gonna happen
and I mean teaching is broader than than
that and then it offers no opportunity
for that at office no opportunity for
redemption no there's no opportunity for
anything else it's just that it I don't
like zero tolerance yeah you know I just
never did I thought that was oh but
Christus isn't zero tolerance you're
guilty this is zero times you're going
to reward you for hey they have the
hearing well I would object to
final paperwork as we got referred yeah
but found innocent well I'm sorry that
you get it if you're found innocent but
here's the thing if if I send them to
the board they're guilty yeah because
I've cause you know
all right the only the only way I'm
going to send a student to the board is
if I'm a hundred percent sure it's it's
plagiarized because I don't want to send
a student to the board otherwise I'm not
gonna do it the administration is afraid
there's too much Wow - will oh you
shouldn't do this anymore on so this
isn't right this where it goes to the
admission thing I think so I think the
instructors I viewed my sanction as sort
of middle of the road you get a zero on
the assignment you don't get to read
through it and I tell you knock it off
don't plagiarize again if you do it
again I'll refer you right some
professors really do turn a blind eye
they're like I don't want to deal with
this at all let's take the paper right
other professors will immediately like
come down hard I want this student
kicked out of my class professors can
get really bent out of shape about it
you know but even like they're gonna get
out of my class they would want that
without them going to the board they'd
be like I just want this student removed
you know is when they do these ratings
you know so we'll replace my professor
do they have a checklist I said this
professor referred five people this last
semester they don't count that in there
no you know they they do is they they
check like how difficult your class is
how you rate the class is it good you
know and you know if you what you want
is actually a rating that says the class
is difficult but he's a really good
professor because that means that you're
doing your job and then they'll put in
comments like expect to write a lot of
papers with this this person or became a
student who's doing the rating be
vindictive because yes yeah well then
this is sort of a funny odd thing yeah
she she was she is up she was only hired
oh my god was she bad with the readings
but anyway she this is
with some experimental film class or
whatever or whenever our classes but she
just gave a scathing ready so now she's
on the number 10 bus and who shows up
with the professor than she sits next to
it's anonymous
um no she who would this was no no no
the when you rate them before yeah I
know but the Chiba did it perfect knew
who this was okay so she'd met set them
screaming she was o ye is free yeah Oh
so anyway okay cuz Kate would tell me
this Isis that's just brutal did you rip
the other number two I said did you
weren't even you know I mean I challenge
a lot of what she said cuz I thought she
you know was off the wall anyway it says
no no no I'm holding my position and she
made a good argument and all this kinda
thing but now the professor sis next to
her and now they've got this long right
on number ten and they literally talked
it through and one side your perspective
in her perspective what was actually
going on and they really became almost
friends onto that I thought that was
really interesting so you know that's
actually a good segue back into this
stuff with the Chesterton when so you
could you can have people that are like
diametrically opposed but Chesterton
portrays them over and over again like
it in a ball across or in the man who
was Thursday if you can see the other
person as a person and they actually
engage them and not like see them as a
person like you know kumbaya circle we
all just we say oh we're all the same no
we would recognize that we're different
from each other we actually hold
sometimes diametrically opposed
positions but we're still willing to
treat each other with you know respect
or friendship or charity or things like
that that creates an even even stronger
bond and Chesterton had that was with
George Bernard Shaw I mean George
Bernard Shaw is like way on the other
end of things so many issues compared to
Chesterton but they would get together
and have have a great time arguing and
fighting together and so do the sort of
things they don't like the characters in
the ball the cross they become like the
best of friends but I think this you
know right or flight thing yeah maybe
x is just triggered in some people's
minds I don't know you mean where we
respond very quickly well I know read
the board but as you describe it yeah
that these two people that seem like
they're on opposite ends of the work or
if their worldview or whatever yeah
can't tolerate that the one believes
what the other one does because it
threatens their sense of reality and
integrity they they're intolerant to
being able to say well you can believe
that yeah I mean we can have a rational
discussion about it and I don't feel
threatened that you're gonna take
something away from me but these a lot
of people yeah these two don't have
either of them they're they're not
they're not they're not doing what you
just described and they're also not
simply threatened and who they are by
the other person's exist but just
trigger to go to fight and they and they
live in a society which won't let you
fight which which opposes tolerance on
everybody that's part of what what just
sort of a cheap tolerance you could say
right well Simon Gregory in America you
know I mean it was Thursday think that's
the same way in the end because they're
both I mean he's got anarchists talking
with it's almost like a yeah and and
Syme who's almost like this you know
divine you know he's get himself so
elegant on there and and and they're
having you know but they're having that
they're having that dialogue they're
just know and it's it's an example of
coming together with different opinions
different point of views and different
things and yet they work they understood
some love they were friends even though
they were over here you know I mean they
were still yeah and it might go back to
sort of uh maybe Chesterton has kind of
anachronistic and this maybe he views it
as a kind of chivalry or something you
know but it is possible for us to do in
in other ways but but I agree with your
your comments they said because the
other the two parties don't come to
blows if they can see each other as a
person as a fellow human being
yeah but the seeds of racism are that we
don't see that other person as their
three-fifths of a person or something I
mean go backward we're not a person or
not a person and just like you know
women in terms of being able to vote
yeah are so long well they're not really
you know one the ruling class they're
just your whatever reason like I've
given how much how much of a beef people
have with the new slate of women in
Congress you know I think there's a lot
of people were like but it is this
failure to see them as a fellow human
being yeah you know and when that gets
blocked however it gets black
biochemical culturally educated just the
people used to run those looking to
listen to a media everyday yeah you know
then that is what creates the seeds of
dissension and destruction yeah so this
is one of the things I was going to
bring out the personalism is a
philosophical movement and chesterton as
far as I know never I'd like identified
himself as a personal a little bit later
movement in like European and American
ideas but I think you can say Chesterton
was a personalist and what makes a
person a personalist
is the commitment that what
fundamentally you know there's all sorts
of values out there but there's a value
intrinsic to the human person that we
don't want to reduce to any of these
other values so you're not just your job
you're not just your your social role
you're not just your class you're not
just this you're not just this year you
are you are another person and whether
you live or dying matters even if you
don't make a contribution you know I
think that something running through his
ideas in his work
pretty pretty heavily and you know it
gets brought out like what you're
talking about with it gets right up to
two two ways one what is what exactly
what you're talking about when we D
personalize somebody we treat their
dehumanize them right we treat them as
if they're now
really a person maybe they're just a
threat you know or maybe they're just a
thing to buy and sell or maybe they're
just you know if we think men and women
and traditional roles maybe they they're
just the the not even person the thing
that makes my dinner right if we do that
then we you know it was very bad of
course for the person who were doing
personal I think it's also bad for us
because we preclude ourselves from the
possibility of actually being able to
see the reality of the other person and
to be in a relationship with them
anything more than a superficial
relationship you know so yeah that's
that's good the last thing I was going
to talk about this this notion of
distributism he and his brother and
Hilaire Belloc were influenced by you
know the encyclical rerum Annavaram as
as many other people were and if you if
you read the Ray Romano varam the the
pope leo xiii is articulating something
that would be a different kind of social
theory like when we talk about you know
conservative liberal or you know we're
talking about economic theories with
like you know communism way on this side
and like unrestricted free market
capitalism on this side and another
things maybe like you know social
democrat in here it may be our american
system in here distributism is in a
certain way and kind of old-fashioned he
wants to bring back some things from the
past but it also viewed itself as a new
way forward for the future it never
really caught on quite frankly it was
not a very successful political program
but there's still people out there today
there's a distributist review that you
can you can see online people are still
contributing to it and then so there's
still some people into it and the idea
was that none of these isms were
actually on track there should be some
private property but it should be small
restricted
chesterton actually said the problem
with capitalism is not that there's too
many capitalists it's not that there's
that there's not enough because
capitalists should be small it shouldn't
be these massive industries that suck up
everything else thinking about for
example what what the tech industry's do
we have all this great you know
innovation happening with small
companies startups and then what's a
startups goal to get bought by Google
Microsoft and Amazon used to be in the
day Yahoo but Yahoo is kind of a you
know a goner I think or a license oh
yeah exactly yeah but the seed money
actually comes that these startups need
it comes from those big it's not so
comes from that miss part yeah I mean
yeah you know the big companies doing
okay and then they know then they get in
on what's actually developing isn't
gonna be something material worth while
yeah or or that they just can't control
it
yeah so somebody else doesn't come and
take away you know the the new way of
building any electric they go so
Chesterton would have been totally
against that he would have been you have
been against there being huge
corporations he'd have been against the
idea of you're essentially developing a
company so that you can sell it to
somebody else he said that you know this
isn't sort of the what the railroad of
arm was saying to you got to stay closer
to the ground it's called some you know
subsidiarity things should be handled at
the proper level and the goal of the
marketplace should not be to generate
you know more and more zeros it should
be to actually generate more and more
good stuff and the good stuff shouldn't
be just trickling down to everybody it
should be right there at the foundation
so that you you know you may have poor
but the poor shouldn't be living a
really crappy life you know that
shouldn't be what's required in order to
make things work and the idea is is you
don't want to have like central control
of everything you want things to be
controlled at the levels where they can
more responsive I think a lot of people
like that idea how to put it in practice
that's tough he had the idea of like we
should go back to medieval guilds ready
I don't think concept that I've used is
we talk about for profit or not for
profit yeah yeah I use the term
especially with not-for-profits or not
perhaps I say you know you should be for
social profit yeah and the only say even
corporations that we call for financial
profit yeah has an element of
accountability for social profit just
like they're now okay yeah waiting for
some of their social consciousness or
for what they're doing to the
environment yeah or that they're you
know not investing in tobacco companies
zero although they're doing local
initiatives like they're buying local
there hey I mean they're doing all kinds
of different things so yeah I can say
that some some of those are consumer
oriented companies because they don't
want to piss off potential customers
especially customers that they say are
at the vanguard and others will follow
yeah so they say we're going to put
soles solar cells or panels you know on
our roofs and get increasing percentages
of all of our electricity from you know
renewable energy sources yeah and then
somebody will come to appreciate that
we're paying twenty five cents percent
or whatever more temporarily for our
electricity and that will be our payback
yeah not because they're good upstanding
moral people but because view a social
profit is something that's important
yeah it's like everyone's like
restaurants that are serving sustainably
harvested fish right there's things I'm
just saying yeah there's there's forms
of accountability that can be placed
corporations that doesn't necessarily
say you can't be a billion dollar
corporation at some point or now
so they yeah you just hold them
accountable and and as more people I
think it comes down to the customer it's
just like you're you're now
- you know if the citizens don't ever go
before the council they think they don't
care well yeah I said - whatever I'm
doing you know so if more customers or
clients whatever yeah has specifications
that says I'm not going to come there
because you don't we pay $8 an hour not
$15 now where you're making no progress
you know to get over this minimum wage
problem we have and just wages or
whatever the situation is well you know
in some sense I think it's partially in
the hands or possibility of the consumer
or the citizen or the client to make
these things happen
yeah I mean come together to do things
not necessarily that we have to wait for
a government or some organization to
come down in sort of a penalty way yeah
I think Chester did we agree with you on
that he would be happy to see that
because that would be a sort of again
happening at the the appropriate level
he was pretty distrustful of government
since well he seemed to think that like
when they when they did the best job
they were at you know at worst
incompetent you know I don't disagree
yeah I mean I've worked with a lot of
governments and I just think they're
just you know I yeah there is something
about having a profit motive that
organizes behavior and focuses on yes it
can lead to abuses ingredient other bad
things you know cheating and dump and
[ __ ] in the river or whatever when
nobody's looking but you know that you
can repair but when you don't have that
driving force for why are we here what's
our mission how do we get it done how do
we measure it how do we have better
outcomes and quite frankly most
not-for-profits including governments we
are not-for-profit you know don't have
that and they meander and they waste and
they fail to get things done let me let
me run an idea of past year this is just
my own sort of experience but I've been
thinking about this
lately because I've been working in a
government-run school again for the
first time in a long time and you know
I've worked and I was in the army and
worked in a lot of various government
things including educational things and
it's not so black and white as this but
I just want to say throw it out there in
a very black-and-white form many of the
people that I encounter are incredibly
helpful and in you know government
organizations are incredibly helpful
they will explain things to you and then
there's many many as well and sometimes
many more who are just time servers will
not help you at all
they've got the rules that that they've
got and they're comfortable with them
and they that protect them and they they
wouldn't like their proverbial they
wouldn't piss on you if you were on fire
you know that sort of thing and there's
probably some people in between - right
but my experience has been there's a lot
of these a lot of these you've what do
you think would you say they don't like
I think the sad thing is some
governments didn't say we paid top
dollar we have good people we hire
professionals and then we let them loose
we don't micromanage them or whatever
okay but what I've seen and I know I say
I work for different I mean as a
consultant yeah an outsider you know
coming in working for them yeah not an
organizational change in me and these
things yeah just so I observe these you
I unfortunately see sometimes they do
hire good intelligent educated people
but then over a period of time sometimes
don't think that long people just sort
of eye hits you that were dumb dumb but
let's just say they acculturate
themselves - what's not really required
yeah and why bust my ass in fact this is
like and this can be even under an
assembly line so
you take somebody news in there it's got
all these ideas yes you know you
shouldn't be doing it that way and you
could do a better this way yeah they
don't want that they said just don't
rock this boat yeah and then if that
person is still too much of a burr under
their saddle
they'll work to get them out yeah I mean
by saying bad things or making up [ __ ]
or whatever yeah you know and this is
like 40 years ago who got thrown and
what are these big bats really and if I
was a crime for a long time then they
said well because there's a motorcycle
gang in this thing and they were
stealing stuff that he was gonna turn
him in because they wouldn't stop
stealing stuff from a paper mill you
know but it was a bio terrible death and
insurance their own shells you know if
you think about like who actually who
produces things right the people who are
actually it's almost like the Peter
Principle
right and the old Peter Principle
everyone rises the level of their
incompetence before they get there
they're actually doing productive work
and then they get promoted and they're
no longer doing it you get the
conscientious people and they're doing
way more work than they need to be doing
and then you got the people are just
time service and it's not like they're
not doing any work they are like you
know because they'll get fired if they
don't do it but there are other people
who come to say government employment
yeah particularly because they don't
want to have that just funding as they
would see it sense of responsibility to
produce and to be engaged and yet they
rather have sort of even if they take a
20 percent less sour or something they
think at the outset they'll think but I
will have my job just can't right here
on this piece of paper yeah and somebody
asked me to step out of this I say no
this is what I'm here for so if you know
you're underwater and you're buried
because happened and I could certainly
help you out you're not going to
not easily yeah babby so they should
hire you an assistant they shouldn't
come over to me because yeah I'm just
pushing things around here I mean so
it's that fortunate but because it's
that what I call actively managed and
but this is someone that goes back to
human nature to I meet people some
people are hungry for information and
knowledge and others to see that as I
paid my 18 years in school and andar
yeah well I know that I'm looking at
this two minutes and excellent
discussion as always and glad to see you
here too next time it's Mary Shelley
we're doing Frankenstein but I put in a
few other lesser-known things as well
[Music]